welcome to on the level broadcasting
from the blues network studios here in
beijing my name is fergus thompson
every three years the results from the
pisa assessment that's the
program for international student
assessment come out to much media
ferrari in 2012 students from shanghai
scored top in the three subjects looked
at which are math science and reading
and this was the second time in a row
that shanghai had triumphed indeed asian
students or students from asian
countries tended to dominate the top six
or seven areas of this so are schools in
china super schools what really goes on
in these schools and should countries
like the united states and indeed europe
as well be ringing their hands at the
success of chinese students while
problems are emphasized in the
educational systems in our countries
well to discuss this i'm joined by an
expert in the field uh john suitein
zhang is a graduate of yale university
he was born in china but emigrated to
canada with his family at a young age
and was educated there after college he
spent some time as a journalist in china
and also as a un official he then moved
back to china to work in education he
consults for tinghua university high
school in beijing one of china's more
prestigious high schools and he has
written a book called creative china in
which he looks at the problem of
creativity and innovation and indeed
education in general in china thanks
foreign welcome to on the level
now uh this
pisa program for international student
assessment can you tell me a little bit
more about this and and what it actually
tests sure um every three years the oecd
working with governments around the
world administer the program for
international student assessment
and it's a test of a nation's education
system
and for the past uh two pieces
the first of 2009 and the second in 2012
china has
placed number one
and in fact actually the top five spots
are dominated by asian countries so
right now there's a lot of concern in
europe and especially in america
uh because america didn't do very well
on the pisa
that uh the future now belongs to china
it belongs especially to east asia
because
as chinese kids and as east asian kids
are focused on learning stem subjects
like
math and science american kids are now
just playing sports they're on facebook
too much
and they're not really focused on
learning the skills they need to be
global competitive in the future so
right now there's a real concern that
the future belongs to china do you feel
that these concerns are are
worth paying attention to
is it something that educators in the
rest of the world need to be worried
about yeah i mean um
when shanghai
uh placed first in 2010 when uh when it
was announced in 2010 uh that shanghai
was number one
there was a meteor firestorm united
states
and um
they called it uh america's
moment um in the idea that this is a
wake-up call for american education that
this is this is uh really bad because
shanghai is number one america's 23rd
america is way behind china
and i think that
uh it became so it drew so much
immediate attention because
uh media loves fear right fair cells so
there's an element of fair mongering uh
to the the piece of scores but there's
also an element of
concern
because right now in america everyone
agrees that the american school system
is dysfunctional and the reason why is
that kids are now becoming more
disengaged from learning and right now
in china
if you go to any schools chinese kids no
matter what the issues are they're
really focused on learning and there's a
respect for teachers that doesn't really
exist anymore in north america or in
europe and kids love math they love the
sciences
a lot of engineers in the future for the
global economy are going to produce in
east asia so i think that yeah i mean
the issue is overblown
the chinese school system isn't that
much better than the american school
system but at the same time the trend is
that china is moving towards
a better better school system in the
united states is still um there's all
hang-wrangling going on in the united
states right now now there's something
just a curious point there we're
comparing countries like the united
states and sweden and the united kingdom
with shanghai rather than china but what
i was wondering is is the comparison
going to be accurate because if you
factored in 100 000 poorly funded
chinese rural schools would you get the
same sort of overall score i think
that's a great point i think that right
now in china because china is such a
huge country with 1.3 billion people
it's trying to educate basically
20 million chinese students you're gonna
have wide disparity um in china shanghai
is one of china's richest cities uh it
is a coastal city so it's access to
um it's very it's basically very
cosmopolitan
it's a very forward-looking and it's a
very in terms of education resources
very well endowed city some of the best
schools in china are in shanghai so
you're right in that china is not
representative of china but at the same
time sean has 20 20 million people
now that's a lot of people so if it's
educating its students well uh it's
still producing a lot of future
entrepreneurs engineers for the service
of chinese economy in the future now uh
you have uh
worked in the chinese educational system
and you were brought up and educated in
the canadian system what are the big
differences between the two thinking
about it off the top of my head i would
say the big difference is that in canada
we're very focused on equity and
mobility issues so the idea is that we
want to make sure that all kids have
access to a decent education so there's
a real emphasis on fairness and equity
in canada now the great thing about
canada is that there's so much emphasis
on equity that all the canadian schools
are the same so it doesn't really matter
which school you go to and there's more
emphasis on how you make the most out of
your experience while you're in canadian
schools so i think that's a great thing
about canada
china is a very competitive system it's
a very elitist very competitive system
that sorts students from from from day
one basically so you have the best
uh lmd schools
servicing or feeding into the best high
schools which then
feed into the best universities
and it's a very it's a very unfair
system because
you know development trajectory of kids
of any adult it's not a linear
trajectory you don't know how kid is
going to perform at age 18 based on his
test scores at age six
and you don't know how a kid is going to
perform in life based on his academic
performance in college look at steve
jobs right he's a college dropout mark
zuckerberg bill gates are all cost
dropouts so there's no real indicator of
future success based on uh one's
performance in school
um
but in china that's taken for granted
the assumption in china is that if
you're a smart kid at age six you're
you'll still be a smart kid at age 18
and you'll still be a smart kid at age
40. um so it's a really unfair elitist
system it's also a very high pressure
system there is an exam system here
called gaucho which is the university
entrance exam sort of across the country
and everything is geared as you say from
from kindergarten upwards to getting uh
good marks in this exam what what about
this exam what are the pressures like on
students and the leader on parents and
teachers the gaucho
which translates translates into the
national college entries examination in
english so in june and early june for
three days uh over the course of six
subjects a student takes
tests and depending on his performance
on the gao cow that will determine which
school
the student will go to which college the
student will go to now from a chinese
perspective this isn't considered the
fairest most objective
um
indicator of
a student's um academic performance and
his ability to do well in college so
from a chinese perspective the calcao is
a fair way
of to basically allocate scarce
education resources but because these
three days are so important it's less to
it's led to a very stressful high
pressure education environment where
from day one the student and we're
talking like you know three or
four-year-old kids are subjected to
rigorous testing
extra classes
and constant nagging from parents and
teachers and there's really because of
the gaucho a death of childhood in china
if the chinese system is doing so well
on an international scale why are more
and more chinese parents sending their
kids abroad not only to study at
university but now in increasing numbers
in high schools in north america and
europe that's a great question and
that's really the paradox of china's
school system right now because as you
say peace because of pisa shanghai is
considered considered the envy
of um
of all educators and teachers and
parents around the world but if you
actually look at what's going on there's
an increasing amount of immigration
in china where chinese who can afford to
talk about middle class and wealthy
chinese they're choosing to opt for
canada new zealand america where the
school system is less high pressure
whether whether the ecosystem did not
perform as well as the transgression on
the psum and what's going on basically
is that right now in china for the past
few years there's a real concern among
chinese parents that the chinese school
system is actually hurting
their kids they have one child and this
child is basically all their future
hopes and dreams whatever curiosity
whatever creativity
whatever imagination whatever empathy
the child has
before he or she enters the school
system is killed within one or two years
so you so i've been to a grim picture
well i've been to elementary schools in
china
and i sit on sit in on classes grade one
class you have kids asking questions
raising their hands asking questions
they're excited they're enthusiastic
about learning
they want to participate and what the
teacher does is basically say to the kid
don't ask questions if you raise your
hand if you ask questions you're a
troublemaker
they take whatever enthusiasm for
learning whatever curiosity the kid has
and basically
just you know
shoves it out the door so you look at
grade two or grade three three kids
they're all standing in line
very well behaved very obedient and
their eyes are blank you look at grade 1
kids their eyes are shiny they're
smiling they're curious by grade 2 or
grade 3 their eyes are kind of blank
kind of lifeless and it was really
heartbreaking for me to see when i visit
these schools but that is a real issue
for for trans parents to see their kids
die like this well if if parents as you
say recognize this and there seems to be
some sort of feeling in society that
this is not the way to go
is there
some sort of idea of reform within the
official dom here within the ministry of
education i know i know you work on some
pilot projects uh which which are
involved in a sort of an alternative uh
way of of looking at this and sort of
avoiding the ecosystem what about the
official perspective everyone in china
recognizes there has there has to be
education reform in china now it's
urgent it's necessary and it's going to
determine the future of china in 2010 uh
prime minister wenzel
launched
to the public uh education reform
blueprint calling for more individuality
for more creativity for more freedom in
chinese schools less homework for kids
more time to play more time to explore
their own interests and right now what
educators are doing is trying to
implement this policy at a grassroots
level
what we're finding as educators is that
there's a lot of resistance from parents
the reason why
is that
let's just say that you're not rich you
can't afford to immigrate or send your
kid to a private school in england or to
united states well kao kao is really
your only chance at a better life the
gaucho has been for thousands of years
seen as the only way for
not so well-off chinese to rise in a
chinese system so if they were from the
gao cow
and there are a lot they want
to change with the gaucho works that is
fundamentally destabilizing from the
perspective of most chinese parents
because they think that
they lead is basically taking their
the elite is basically
sabotaging their only way to
increase their social mobility in china
so right now there's so much tension and
so much conflict going on in china
because on one hand you have educators
trying to
spread education reform but your parents
trying to push back because because
they're worried
that educate education reform will screw
their kid over right how do teachers fit
into this
are they for the reform are they against
it or again is it a sort of a a conflict
within within the the body well i mean
most teachers that i know most teachers
that i've interviewed and who i've met
want the best possible future for
their students
that's why they enter the teaching
profession that's their pride
as teaching professionals so they feel
that
as teachers they really need to get
their kids to focus on doing well on
tests on learning subject matter well
and on being able to regurgitate it in
on on tests because that's really what
the chinese system does that's how you
indicate you're successful in china by
doing well on tests so
teachers on one hand you know they sort
of grew up in the alcohol system so
there's certain like emotional loyalty
to gao cow but on the other hand they
feel that as teachers for me exactly and
they also but they also feel that
if they don't really emphasize testing
in
the classroom
their students are going to be left
behind
so again even though from the top and
from beijing
from very wealthy parents and from top
educators there's this real push for
education reform
in china
at the grassroots level there's a lot of
concern there's a lot of skepticism and
there's a lot of cynicism
so
there has to be a it's a communication
issue there's a communication gap where
things are being properly articulated to
the grassroots as we mentioned earlier
many chinese students do
head abroad that the number going to
study abroad has tripled in a decade
what sort of
problems do you see chinese students
facing when they go
outside china to study particularly say
in north america right so um
a lot of chinese parents believe that
study abroad is a panacea to all china's
education problems that if i send my kid
who's not doing very well in the chinese
school system and i sent them off to
united states for high school this kid
is going to
get into yale harvard become steve jobs
and win a nobel prize there's this real
myth and mentality
within china's parents that they think
that listen i spent some money millions
of dollars send my kid abroad and all
our problems are avoiding this pressure
system
sure sure but what transparents don't
realize and but they do realize is once
their student their kid is actually in
the united states is that the training
system does not really work well with
other systems so another way of saying
this is that chinese students in china
are taught to behave a certain way that
lets them you know basically
get along in china
in china the transit school system does
not allow you to ask does not permit you
to ask questions doesn't want you to
think for yourself doesn't want you to
stand out
so these kids go to america and suddenly
in these china in these american schools
in these american colleges the professor
wants them to ask questions the
professor wants them to stand out the
professor wants them to be
independential creativity and they
cannot emotionally adapt to sort of this
environment so the irony is that yes the
chinese school system is stressful for
these kids but you take chinese students
who are
indoctrinated in the system and you put
them in an american setting it's even
more stressful for them because they
become socially alienated from
from their professors and from their
classmates how about if they're moving
earlier because there is a move towards
people actually studying high school in
the united states indeed some schools in
the united states are almost
majority chinese students
do they adapt any better yeah so what
we're finding is that maybe like 5-10
years ago the trend was as you say
moving
the trend was these chinese students
moving to america for college but now
parents are for many reasons sending
their
kids to america for high school and
possibly even
for junior high school a lot of families
are also choosing to immigrate and we're
finding is that these students adopt
better to america than
the chinese students who go for college
so
so and always saying this is that we're
finding that the school system is very
effective at indoctrinating chinese
students in a certain way that does not
permit them to engage different cultures
the uh
this move or these students that go
abroad uh it would seem to be a marriage
made in heaven you've got students in
china who want to pay money and who want
to get a good education in in a
prestigious university abroad and you've
got universities who need money and want
high performance students right so
what's not to like about that right so i
think um
i think that a lot of people believe
that this is a marriage made in heaven
but if you actually look at what's
happening it's a marriage made in hell
and the reason why is that a lot of
these chinese students are going to
america because they can't get to
picking qinghua and fudan in dalton and
always saying this is that these are not
the best students going to america these
are probably
um
students who failed out of the chinese
school system so academically they're
not well equipped to do well in school
for a variety of reasons
if you look at
america all these schools are actively
trying to recruit chinese students are
state schools
with very limited funding so you're
looking at you know the
higher school system the indiana
illinois uh wisconsin california uh
because of the recession right on
america the state uh legislators have
cut the budget for higher for higher
education so now they're desperate for
chinese students who can pay three times
as much as local students
but the problem is that
these schools are not equipped to deal
with chinese students so i mean i visit
these schools and
these chinese students go to america
and
they're given no support so these
students might write essays there's no
feedback and you can also make the
argument i think it's a very important
argument is that there's real
dysfunction going on in the american
higher education system because look at
the stats there's one trillion
in student debt uh students are
um student debt rental is considered
like one of the biggest problems right
now in american education 60
of
american high school of american
students when i graduated from college
and sort of like you know american
educators think that oh chinese students
it's a temporary solution it's a bandage
to this problem like long term there has
to be a real restructuring of american
higher education and long term there has
to be a real restructuring of chinese
chinese education so
i don't think this is a marriage made in
heaven i think there's some real serious
issues that we need to look at
you wrote about the problems of
american universities recruiting chinese
students
and
you said that
they could perhaps do it in a more
effective manner that certainly at the
moment they were recruiting students
perhaps with the wrong criteria what
could they do to to to recruit the
students that will succeed well right
now the issue in uh in this process is
that you have chinese students who want
to go abroad and you have american
schools desperate for money so a lot of
emphasis is on trying to fill as many
spots as possible with full paying
chinese students and there is enough
emphasis on are we recruiting the right
students and are we equipping these
students to do well in these schools so
i think that um these american schools
are using agents in china and these
agents are basically head hunters they
make money based on the number of people
members training students they can
recruit to go to america and they don't
really care about
does it make sense for these kids to
go to to america and like the irony of
this is that a lot of these schools who
do recruiting are public state
universities founded on a mission to
expand america's middle class to expand
the idea of democracy in america and
they've basically forsaken their public
school mission and moving towards more a
corporatist mentality so i think that
first and foremost these schools indiana
ohio they need to rediscover the public
mission
mandate
and then they need to
take a serious look at who they're
recruiting from china and whether or not
these schools are equipping these
students with
the right skill set to succeed in uh in
america
now
i mentioned earlier that the number of
students that are the students from
asian countries dominated the top of
those of those pisa rankings do you feel
it's uh not perhaps just the
administrative system in in in china
that produces uh these high scoring
students but something to do with asian
culture and and and
reverence for education um i feel that
this is a very controversial question um
and this is my own personal opinion but
i feel that there's a real emphasis
on outcomes there's a very utilitarian
mentality so asians love tests if you
look at
the pizza but not just a piece of you
look at the sat you look at any
examination asians if they participate
tend to dominate and the reason why is
that the energy system in east asia
singapore south korea japan china it's
all predicated on a student's ability to
do well on tests it's not about real
learning it's not about creativity it's
not about giving students space to make
mistakes it's all about doing well on
tests that's a mentality that does that
doesn't really happen
in the west and that's why you know we
find that chinese students they do very
well in a school system where
the tasks are algorithmic
and
the students don't really have that much
space to make mistakes but when they
enter society when they start companies
or when they are forced to work
on open-ended projects
in multicultural environments they don't
do so well
there's a real problem in china right
now in recruiting good managers
good
and good entrepreneurs and basically
creative thinkers but if you look at you
know accountants computer programmers
china has an abundance of these people
uh one exception to that that that
ranking was finland which seemed to do
quite well in in these and i know that
you visited the the country
is there anything that that that the
chinese education system could learn
from finland i believe there's a lot the
chinese school system can learn from
finland there are many reasons why the
finland does very well on
international assessments not just pisa
but also tim's
reason one is that there's a real
emphasis on making sure each child is
educated well so at starting eight
months of age a child can choose to
enroll in a free public daycare program
administered by
well-educated teachers
so and this is free so regardless of
whether you're
poor or rich you can have your child
access this tremendous daycare system
and a lot of research tells us that the
most formative years in a kid's life is
basically from age one to age six a lot
of a lot of the neural wiring the child
will need to succeed in life is
basically formed during that age but you
look at a place like china and you know
if you're wealthy then you can actually
send your kid to a very expensive
daycare program but if you're not
wealthy then your kid stays at home sure
but finland is a relatively rich country
it can't afford to do this china has the
problems of numbers and the the the
funds that he can put into that's that's
a great argument and i will make the
argument that actually the cost of
educating a child in the daycare system
it should be a lot less expensive than
in the universe system we're finding in
china right now is a lot of funding a
lot of money is expended in the first
two years when a student leaves college
and enters the workforce and the reason
why is that
employers find that fresh college
graduates don't have the skills they
need
to do well in the workplace so they need
to spend they need to invest two to four
years
in re training the student to do well in
the in the workplace that's a tremendous
investment on their part they have no
choice because they need workers
now but you can you can make argument
that you know what if the chinese
government were to where to invest a
little bit of this money in the daycare
system the results would be a lot better
but it's a very different mentality the
mentality in finland is how can we make
sure that each
of our kids is empowered to do well in
life whereas in china it's basically the
rich looking out for themselves and
basically ignoring the rest of society
right you have written a book called
creative china in which you speak a lot
about
the
about empathy and how empathy can lead
to innovation something which the
chinese government has said is extremely
important for the
country to continue with its successful
path uh
can you elaborate a little bit on that
on empathy in china and and what it has
to do with education yeah i mean i love
talking about empathy um empathy is
something that i discovered that was
really emphasized in the finished school
system so when i went to finland at you
know starting grade six
kids were being taught the importance of
empathy you asked any kid in finland
who's like 10 years or older when
empathy is and the person will say right
away empathy is the ability to put
yourself in another person's shoes can
you not get the same answer from a child
you empathy there's no words of empathy
in chinese empathy
historically has never been taught or
emphasized in china china right now
has a real problem with empathy there's
a classic story
classic news story
that happened three years ago where this
little girl she was 66 years old maybe
she was running over by a car not once
but twice
bystanders came they just stood around
her and they just looked there was real
no emotional attachment to strangers now
in china there's a lot of like emotional
attachment to your relatives and the
people you know in your in your quasi
network but there's really little
empathy for people you don't know and so
the sort of like social bonds the social
clues that allow side to function don't
really exist in china and that's why you
know there's so much
there's so many social problems right
now right now in china but in finland
empathy is really emphasized and that's
why the society is so strong but you
know what empathy is also fundamental
that if you want your student to engage
other cultures and so i feel that in
finland right now they're being very
smart about that because they feel in
the future we live in a global workplace
we're living and working in a global
workplace it's a global economy we're
going to win we're going to we're going
to need to produce students who are able
to work with other cultures but not just
work on the cultures also manage
other cultures as well and something
that finland does very well because it
emphasizes empathy it's something that
china is going to struggle with and
that's why
uh we have so many um cases where
there's so much misunderstanding going
on between china and the rest of the
world because china's really can't
understand
how the rest of the world thinks
and
china right now is considered black box
to the rest of the world so i think that
as educators
we really need to educate a new
generation of chinese students who are
able to
have empathy and who are able to
understand and respect other cultures
and that's a way for china to engage the
rest of the world make sure that china's
rise is as smooth um and as peaceful as
possible
well young 13 best of luck in in your
path to
improving china's education system
thanks very much for putting that out
thank you
you